this week on court riga russia climate
of fear boas Nemtsov was an outspoken
critic of russia's President Putin he's
been shot dead in Moscow within sight of
a Kremlin opponents of a Russian
government know about living dangerously
many say the country is ruled by
insecurity suspicion and fear thousands
turned out for both Nemtsov funeral
it appears Russia is splitting into two
irreconcilable camps those opposed to
visit of Putin and those who support him
propaganda and attacks on independent
media and making the split ever deeper
Nemtsov is just one of the many critics
of a government who have been killed in
mysterious circumstances
who's behind the shootings and who
benefits and they designed secure the
government's power or to destabilize the
country what does it mean for Russian
society your host this week
Melinda crane and those are the
questions we want to explore on this
edition of quadriga welcome and we'll do
so with three people who've been closely
following events in Russia and Russian
relations with the West it's my pleasure
to welcome my colleague Christian Ripa
he's special correspondent from the
dortch for the Deutsche Welle reporting
regularly from Moscow he was head of DWS
Moscow bureau from 2002 to 2007 he's
been with Deutsche Welle delos since
1993 including stints as bureau chief in
Brussels and Berlin and it's great to
have Anton Winiarski back on the program
he is a u.s. journalist of Russian
origin who regularly writes on Ukraine
and Russia he's currently the chief
German politics and economics
correspondent for The Wall Street
Journal and previously reported from
Moscow for The Washington Post and The
Associated Press and Anthony Patterson
is with us he's the Berlin correspondent
for the London Daily newspaper the
independent he has worked as a foreign
correspondent in Paris Bonn Warsaw
Vienna and Berlin reporting extensively
on the fall of the Iron Curtain for UPI
and the BBC
and in memory of boris nemstov I'd like
to begin with a short clip from an
interview that DW did with him in late
2011
of course it's difficult and dangerous
to be in the opposition in an
authoritarian regime aren't you afraid
something might happen to you if you
live in Russia we convey a grade if I
was afraid I'd have left the country so
apparently that changed boris nemstov
went to israel sever for several months
last summer saying that he was fearful
in the fall he filed a police report
because of threats against his life and
two weeks ago he told an interviewer
that he was scared Putin would have him
killed
Christian Clipper you know Moscow well
you've been reporting on Russia for a
long long time what changed between 2011
where Boris Nemtsov could say he was not
afraid to today well I came back to
Moscow last autumn for the first time
since 2007 and I found the city the mood
there completely changed I got the
impression that people sort of started
fighting the West started started
fighting especially the US there's a
mood of war like a pre-war like mood
people are looking for traitors people
are looking for the fifth column of the
West and this can be experienced in
everyday life something which was
completely new to me and I remember when
I drove with my with a taxi from the
airport to the hotel I was saying the
taxi driver from my accent could get
that I have a drum background and asked
me whether I am German or Austrian I
said well 1 John oh yeah Chancellor
she's a puppet of the CIA isn't she
he replied as you know I said no she
isn't and started arguing with him and
then he said ok I won't repeat that
she's not a puppet of the CIA but she
does what Obama tells her to do anton
troyanovsky whether or not the Kremlin
gave the order for an EM sought to be
killed would you say that ultimately it
is responsible to the degree that it is
perhaps manipulating
creating that climate of fear that
Christian trip I just described well
there are a number of the theories that
are circulating around what was behind
this murder that would I think lay some
guilt at the defeat of the Kremlin you
know people are saying if this wasn't a
direct Kremlin hit it could have been
various nationalist groups that have
been riled up by this anger that
Christian disgust and and and could have
led to that we don't know but I think
there's no question that this that this
anger at the West and that there's and
this belief that the West is out to
destroy Russia is gathering so much
force in Russia that we really can't
predict the consequences at this point
and how far it that will go Anthony
Patterson ever since the Ukraine crisis
began media have been speculating about
the rise of a new Cold War this was the
highest level political assassination in
Russia since Vladimir Putin has been in
power do you think it marks a new era
not only for Russia but also for
east-west relations well yes and no
obviously it's shocking and it shocked
everybody in the West but I don't really
think that it's changed the status quo
that much it's interesting that Obama in
this situation has not been leading the
field in negotiations with Russia over
Ukraine it has been left he's left
virtually a vacuum for people like
Angela Merkel and Hollande to move in
and take over an assumed a role Britain
has remained on the sidelines and he
just came in recently I think the
general attitude of the West is that
they're very worried and concerned about
what is going on in in Ukraine and by
these murders and by the climate of
political oppression in Russia but they
don't really see it as a concrete threat
to the world order yet I want to return
in a moment to that big picture to the
larger context including east-west
relations
but first let us try to deconstruct both
the Kremlin response to the killing and
some of the rumors around it Russia may
be in the grip of a climate of fear but
Vladimir Putin's spokesman said directly
after Boris nemtsov's murder that in
fact nobody there
felt threatened by him and that his
killing was a provocation for the
Kremlin if you would please Christian
trippa do some Kremlinology for us and
explain what what is that meant to to
say well this figure this notion that
it's a provocation is something very
common in in Russian propaganda in
Russian political speeches and it goes
back to Soviet times and it's it goes
back to making others holding others
responsible for what is happening in
your country in a very broad sense and
if it comes to political murder two
killings like this it's obvious that
it's a hint and underlying hint every
Russian will understand and reach as
such a hint at Western secret services
or Ukrainian secret service who might
have killed it by resonance of sort of
to cast bad light on the Russian regime
on the Putin regime and on the Kremlin
this is it sounds a bit absurd to my
mind and perhaps to our Western ears but
this is something Russian ears are used
to to get an interpretation like that
and it stunned me when I heard the
Kremlin spokesperson come out with this
provocation theory immediately the very
moment after it had happened and then
when they were casting allegations that
it might have an Islamist background
because Boris Nemtsov openly supported
the Charlie Hebdo movement and there
were other allegations that it might
have been in some context with his
girlfriend some private revenge things
and jealousy thing which is as I read it
just to distract people from what might
be really behind it that the nationalist
move the Russian the Ukraine war what
this war this undeclared war has created
within the Russian society is that the
people who are behind it maybe find
found there okay I want to come right
back to the connection to Ukraine but
first of all Anton troyanovsky of a
little more Kremlinology because here's
the next really puzzling thing the same
Kremlin spokesman said more recently a
couple of days later that there is no
political motive behind the murder and
now the media in Russia apparently are
swirling with speculation that there
could have been personal motives acrost
lover what how how plausible are any of
these rumors and is it really is it
really in doubt that there was a
political element to this well I mean
another back when there were political
elements being thrown out by the Kremlin
I think one one really kind of memorable
way that this has been described
repeatedly is that maybe he was a
sacrificial victim created by the
opposition ahead of this opposition
march that they were planning this past
Sunday but I think this also be a few
facts on that because I think not all of
our viewers are aware he was killed at
the end of last week and there was a big
opposition march that was scheduled for
for the weekend and so one of these
theories that spend thrown out there by
Russian state media is he is Nemtsov was
a sacrificial victim that he was killed
by the opposition in order to rile up
people against Putin ahead of this March
but I think what you speak to in terms
of all these theories being thrown out
there is something we see a lot these
days in the messaging that comes out of
pro-kremlin Russian state media which is
just to kind of flood the zone with
theories of what may or may not have
happened whether it be the Malaysian
Airlines plane that crashed in Ukraine
or whether it be this murder at creating
kind of this atmosphere that we have no
idea what's actually happening we have
no idea what
true and so if these kind of if the West
is throwing out this one theory that it
was Putin behind this murder you know we
don't know and I think that's that's
kind of what's behind all these theories
is to create this climate of uncertainty
so so chiseling away at the idea of
facts is part of creating a climate of
fear definitely I remember very well and
the day afternoons of murder we had this
commemoration March in the very center
of Moscow and they were passing by the
place where he had been killed and there
was one they had been denied a permit
for their official demonstration that
they wanted to have but then when it was
a commemoration March suddenly they were
permitted to to go into the center of
the city you could read the sign
propaganda kills very often in this
commemoration margin this to my mind
exactly sums it up what is happening
there there has been created this
climate this public climate of hatred
against every anyone who sort of
supports or allegedly supports the west
of Western ideas Anthony Patterson there
doesn't seem to be any doubt in the
minds of foreign observers that there
was a political motive behind the
killing the entire diplomatic core of
the European Union for example was
present at the commemoration service for
himself what is the reading in Europe on
the meaning of this killing well I think
that the overall feeling is that it's
sort of whatever whoever was responsible
it definitely feeds into this whole idea
of a conspiracy theory a Western
conspiracy theory against Russia it's a
very useful for Putin for him to sort of
bolster his his campaign in the Ukraine
to create this this feeling that Russia
is under attack and I think if if
statistics are right I mean he's got you
know a 86 percent support of the
population in Russia so he doesn't
really have to worry about a bunch of
liberals in Moscow who attend a
demonstration about himself I mean he's
got
86% of the people behind him he can do
what he wants and this is the worrying
thing I think it's something that's
worrying wiring the West quite a lot
because it's very difficult to deal with
a leader who is operating on that sort
of basis because it's so far removed
from Western concepts of democracy and
diplomacy and we're now ski the exiled
Russian journalist or at least self
exiled Russian journalist Masha Gessen
now living in the u.s. said that she
thinks in all likelihood probably the
Kremlin didn't order the killing but
that to the degree that the Kremlin has
created a loose army of Avengers as she
put it it would in fact be responsible
what does she mean by that what what
what's behind this loose army of
Avengers well in the Ukraine conflict in
the east of that country we've seen a
glorification of these allegedly
independent people fighting for Russian
power and that's starting to happen
within Russia as well that pro-russian
media Pro Russian websites are I should
say pro-kremlin media Pro Kremlin
websites are encouraging people to kind
of take matters into their own hands
whether it be by sort of rooting out
traitors the so-called fifth column
preventing Western it's CIA influence in
the country and yeah that's what Marsha
was referring to there in terms of maybe
if this wasn't a direct again Kremlin
order it was violent perpetrators
believing they're acting on behalf of
the Kremlin I think I mean just real
quick I think the one important thing to
point out about this killing is that it
happened nearly on red square right
across from the Kremlin in one of the
most protected most watched parts of
Russia
so whatever it was it was a killing that
was undertaken very brazenly and
apparently with a lot of premeditation
and planning
I saw one wonderful a most whole story
and description of how many cameras are
on that bridge a Russian writer saying
there's many cameras on that bridge has
beetles in the ground in August or
something some incredible analogy
Christian clipper just a few weeks ago
there was a march in Moscow by a group
called anti my done and they called
explicitly for violence against the
fifth column which I understand to be
opposition agitators and so on and there
were posters that name mr. Nemtsov as
the organizer of the Ukraine revolution
is that the loose army of Avengers that
is guessing means the propaganda branch
we see and we can film but when I would
like to add to what I'm don't just
figure it would just explained to us
there are there is discontent in the
Russian society with the way Putin
handles this campaign in Ukraine there's
a hawkish a right wing faction within
the Kremlin and they have people they
have their supporters in society who
want Putin to act more openly and more
aggressively and some even ask to send
the Russian tanks to Kiev to finish
Ukrainian statehood and these this
discontent these hawkish figures they
have connections to the security
services to the FSB that's what is
well-known and they sometimes appear
together on TV and if we try to
speculate and find out who committed the
murder I think this is the way where
they might be found and this might
explain why they were so ruthless to
choose a place a spot 100 meters away
from the Kremlin wall which as you just
said is under perfect civilians every
suggesting it as a warning to the
Kremlin perhaps even that as a sign as a
signal to those in the Kremlin oh don't
act strong enough in their viewpoint I
don't want a ski you're nodding your
head well I mean that's certainly a
theory you're right the sort of power
structures within the Kremlin as we
understand them are very much about
these various security factions in the
in the government power structure so
whether whether that
I just I was nodding because I hadn't
heard that specific theory before but
it's it's worth noting you remember this
commander of the so-called separatists
in eastern Ukraine Gil King yes a strike
off and he sometimes appears on TV and
asked the Kremlin to finish the job and
send the army officially and and he
openly aggressive Putin attacks him for
not being strong enough in a stance
towards Ukraine and Cindy Patterson it
sounds like a situation that could get
out of control certainly for the Kremlin
itself but is it not perhaps also a
threat to the West you said you had the
sense that people in the West didn't
necessarily think anything has
significantly changed or perhaps don't
see this as a direct threat but it's
certainly very incendiary certainly I
think the main point here is though that
interests are not as directly threatened
as they might be Germany of course is in
the firing line on this because of the
huge business interests that it has in
Russia and these are sort of things that
count but in overall obviously I mean
the situation is reminiscent of when you
what you were saying earlier about
elements operating almost autonomously
to support the regime and the direction
of of Pope in which Putin was going is
reminds me very much of an analogy of
Nazi power the way that some Adolphe
Hitler assumed power with lots of parts
of German society working towards to
Nazi go I'm not saying that Putin is
that of Hitler but there are certain
similarities there and I think everybody
is watching very closely to see what the
next moosa and of course a very very key
element of that strategy in nazi germany
was what the Germans call galaki shall
tongue of the media namely shutting down
all independent media and want lenosky
it's been implicit in much of what we
said but spell out for us the role of
the Russian media in creating this
climate that both of you have described
well the facts are the Kremlin controls
the main TV channels in Russia and TV
remains by far the main way that
Russians get information so the
narrative that's been conveyed with
great intensity and great almost
aggression by these channels is that the
CIA the United States are out to destroy
dismantle Russia and that they're doing
this via the Ukraine crisis that the
u.s. is trying to use the Ukraine crisis
to draw Europe into a war with Russia
you know there's these really martial
kind of elements martial rhetoric
involved here and that pushes and and
that pushes certain buttons in Russia
because there has long been a concern by
Russians that they haven't been treated
fairly by the West and we're kind of
seeing that all come together now let us
get a sampling of Russian public opinion
as it's being shaped by the Russian
media today Yevgeniy cleanups eat
manufactures soft drinks it's doing good
business more than 200 people are
employed in this factory outside of
Moscow so far the businessman hasn't
been affected by EU sanctions on Russia
that could change as soon as one of his
machines needs to be repaired though the
spare parts come from Germany
but the 54 year old is prepared to
accept the potential types of sanctions
since pursuing provides policies they're
important for our long-term outlook the
short-term problems that arise over
price Russia must pay if it wants to be
an independent country promoting the
image of Russia as a global player is
one of putin's biggest priorities it's
won him widespread support to public
opinion appears to be less focused on
the country's economic outlook then on
how it presents itself on the
international stage we have good cough
is a political scientist his research
shows that support for Putin remains
high that he says is down to several
factors the flow of information and the
political sphere the opposition is
depressed demoralized divided and
excluded from political discussion with
alternative views no longer trickle-down
yevgeniy clean etske lives with his
family on the outskirts of Moscow both
he and his wife admire Putin they
believe he's courageous to be pursuing
his own course and that he represents
Russia's interests abroad doesn't allow
himself to be held accountable to anyone
that's why we're proud of our president
but we always knew that Russia's
rebellion against Western dominance and
promotion of its own interests and
independence would come at a price
Christian clipper it is of course a
time-honored concept if things aren't
going that well economically you drum up
an external or internal enemy and get
discontent focused around that what I
don't get is in the age of Internet how
can this work media manipulation sure
but surely Russians could get access to
other information to be quite honest I
don't get it either
Russian Russians to make a vast use of
the Internet is surreal and Internet
nation and so far the Internet is not
yet censored it's free they have access
for example to Deutsche Welle websites
BBC and all international outlets in all
languages but the Russian TV is regarded
as the key sauce and the most
trustworthy source of information they
read Western information they meaning a
vast majority of Russians they read
Western information as part of this
propaganda tricky game against them and
tend to trust their own TV outlets we
have three newspapers in Russia which
are circulate printed and circulated
basically only in Moscow and these
newspapers write command analyze in
according to Western journalistic
standards but as said before they are
distributed only within Moscow they are
read mostly by by businessmen as the guy
we just seen but you can't buy them in
Petersburg you can't buy them in in
Siberia and in other remote areas so in
in Russia and in in these remote areas
and all other cities apart from Russia
its Russian TV that formats the mind the
political mindset of the people
Antonov Suki is there some kind of
cultural affinity for conspiracy
theories or is that much too simplistic
I mean yes I think so but I think there
at all we also see that in Germany and
across the West right people that people
especially in the Internet age can get
drawn in by conspiracy theories pretty
quickly I don't know I think that that
that a big reason why
again why Russian pro-russian program
land media is effective is that it
speaks to fears and prejudices that
Russians had even before this whole
Ukraine thing started I mean you know
like it fits into this mindset when
Russians think about how difficult the
1990s were when capitalism and democracy
came to Russia and that was of course
seen as something that the West the u.s.
brought to Russia and imposed on Russia
to a certain extent it's it's now not
kind of something that's being pulled
out of thin air by pro-kremlin media to
say the West is out to get us
these are suspicions that Russians have
had before and I think that that's why
it's effective Anthony Patterson there
are of course critics even in the West
who say look if there's a siege
mentality in Russia it's partly because
we in the West helped back it into a
corner well yes that's definitely a view
I mean I think it's not disputed that
the West bungled the Ukraine my business
every Ukraine and trying to bring the
Ukraine into the EU the House of Lords
which is normally pretty impartial in in
Britain came to this conclusion last
week I think there has been an
underestimation of Russia if you look at
in terms of history you have a the
Soviet Union which was a vast global
power has been reduced considerably in
influence over the past 25 years it is
and I think Russians in general it's
understandable they feel more
comfortable with a dictatorial ruler who
lays down the law is something that they
used to it's something that is comes
from their history so I don't think that
the Russian reaction in this situation
is is that that extraordinary I think
the intensity of it is though I think
the the levels to which it is being
carried out particularly since the
Nemtsov murder are quite extreme
Christian Tripp I don't want to go into
it in too much depth because it does
take us a bit further afield but just
one word on the backed into a corner
theory I was recently speaking to the
former German Foreign Minister yashka
Fisher who said that at the time he was
in office he received clear overt
statements from Vladimir Putin saying
that Vladimir Putin had no problem with
a closer association between Ukraine and
the EU and that this clearly very
dramatically changed why well it was the
same was true even with NATO regarding
NATO expansion NATO enlargement Russia
until under Yeltsin and under the first
years under Putin supported it and was
not fighting it this enlargement in
general was seen as something very
positive until 2005 2006 because Russia
thought if the EU advances to our
frontiers it will be easier to create an
atmosphere of technology exchange to
move closer to Western technological
standards it was always technological
standards and never Civic standards of a
civic society what they were referring
to but never mind
and why it changed in the middle of some
10 years ago
it's up to analysis definitely
definitely that's my observation when I
was working there as a correspondent the
very bullying US foreign policy under
the Bush administration the George W
Bush administration played at the hands
of the hardliners in the Kremlin
definitely an Tonto an auskey from your
experience would you say that there was
a kind of a switch and if so was it
something you know that I think some
people believe the first presidency
Vladimir Putin that was put in 1 then
Putin comes back put in 2 and it's dr.
Jekyll and mr. Hyde would you say it was
planned long and advanced or was it a
response to factors perhaps in in
foreign relations
well when Putin you remember his Prime
Minister Medvedev took over as president
or was elected as president after Putin
and then there was I think genuine
surprise in the West
or at least genuine maybe disappointment
among Western leaders when Putin decided
to stand for election again after after
Madhvi gives one term there I think
there was some uncertainty about that
and I think there was genuine hope here
in Germany perhaps especially that mid
vada
coming in a kind of a more of an
economically liberal Western oriented
person signaled some kind of switch even
to get even closer to the west and I
think Putin was always seen as the more
conservative ruler in that tandem so I
think it's been kind of an evolution of
on the part of Putin in terms of
relationship with the West
Anthony Patterson the fascinating thing
is that all of you are saying it taps
back into currents that were they are
pre-fall of the wall and the fascinating
thing is last year we celebrated the
25th anniversary of the fall of the wall
and yet clearly we aren't far from past
that era well I mean in Germany
Germany's the victor or as one has done
very well and become enormously
successful as a result of the fall of
the Berlin Wall from a Russian
standpoint if you look at it from a
conservative Russian standpoint it's
done nothing but lost out in terms of
global power global significance and
this plays very much into a hand into
the hands of a leader who wants power
and current clearly enjoys perón wants
to stay in office he can we really call
the these fears and it helps him
enormously so in many senses it's not if
you've got an electorate or the vast
majority of the Russian population feel
safer with this kind of leader it's not
really that surprising that he will
choose to capitalize on that the
interesting thing is Christian twiba
during the Cold War conflicts stayed
cold they basically didn't heat up
because nuclear weapons
a roof on the situation that seems to be
changing when we both attended the
Munich Security Conference recently
there was much talk of hybrid warfare a
new form of warfare that uses the media
that uses soldiers who aren't wearing
its insignia that uses subterfuge and
insinuation in order to wage a kind of a
very foggy lukewarm conflict is poutine
doing that at home as well as abroad is
hybrid warfare something that that
begins at home
well definitely but let me comment on
compare the old Cold War and what we are
going through right now
I think it's right to say that it's much
more dangerous right now than it has
been before because NATO the Western
military alliance and Russia have lost
many tools and means of contact there's
even no longer the famous red telephone
installed so that in case that some
perceptions of military threat go a bit
wild and wrong the general staffs can't
communicate directly so I agree with
those analysts who say that it's much
more dangerous than it has been before I
look at all these military exercises all
these a patrolling which happens in the
Baltic right now where Russian fighter
planes often switch off their
transponders which makes this new Cold
War this new warlike scenario much more
dangerous than it has been Antonio
skiing
hybrid warfare from what we know Nemtsov
himself was doing a lot of research on
Ukraine to try to tie together some of
these patterns to try to identify
Russian soldiers who had died there to
try to provide hard evidence about
Russian involvement in that sense did
the Kremlin have more to fear from him
than it's perhaps letting on well we I
haven't seen any reports yet that what
Nemtsov was working on was going to be
offer some kind of a
explosive new evidence there has already
been a lot of evidence of Russian
soldiers fighting in Ukraine presented
by Russian newspapers some of these
three independent newspapers in Moscow
the Christian mentioned so you know I
don't think there's really a lack of
evidence in Russia right now on the
Internet in the Russian language from
reliable sources indicating that
Russians are fighting in Ukraine it's
more that that information isn't really
getting out to people and isn't being
believed by the majority of people so I
think in himself was more of a of a you
know if we pursue the Kremlin was behind
it in some way theory it's more I think
about scaring people into not trying to
get mixed up into politics there anymore
so you don't believe presenting more
facts would change the public opinion we
saw in our report I think it I think it
could yes I mean if substantial
explosive new facts were presented we
haven't there hasn't been reporting that
that's what in himself was going to do
LT Patterson the Ministry of Internal
Affairs is on the case
it will anything come of that
investigation do you suppose based on
prior experiences and events in Russia
no I think there have been six political
murders over the past twenty years and I
don't think any of them have produced
the people who are really behind it you
you get the gunman or the killer but
they you know never have the idea of
what forces were actually driving this
they so I don't think I think this case
will be very similar I can't see that
it's going to open up a whole box of
worms about the undercurrents of of
Russia does that mean Christian tripper
that this killing is in fact likely to
deter other independent researchers
other members of what's called the
opposite
although in fact it's not an opposition
in any sense that a Western European
country would recognize do you expect it
to have a chilling effect well I'm not
sure but we have to see that the year
position in Russia was weak and split up
into many small groups before me and so
shmurda so this was perhaps designed as
a signal don't unite and don't present
one strong opposition leader this is
something we Western journalists Western
media Western think tanks are always
after who's leading the opposition there
was no one to lead the Opposition in
Russia you had Alexei Navalny en Sophia
it was coincidentally in prison every
time that himself was killed he had been
planning that demonstration with himself
but in fact had been taken away for a
couple of weeks and you have former
prime minister kasi on/off who's leading
is another small faction of the
opposition but there is no no longer a
strong political movement that could
really translate into a party that might
endanger Putin and his rule we did see a
pretty impressive showing at the
memorial for himself of other critics
other voices including people who had
also been in power during the Yeltsin
era as forced himself had been and are
now in disrepute one of them pledged
Russia will be free during the memorial
service that doesn't sound like caving
in in front of threats it's true I think
there will continue to be a portion of
Russians that want to be closer with the
West I mean I think that that's you know
while it's true that Russians maybe feel
bad about having lost the global
geopolitical weight that the Soviet
Union had very many Russians were also
very excited to be able to travel to the
west and by Western products and
become and watch American movies etc and
I and I think that despite everything
the West will continue to have a soft
power impact in Russia and we just have
to see how for how long the kind of
Putin power will be able to go up
against that I think it's not really
clear how that will turn out what do you
think Tony Patterson how can the West
influence this situation and is there an
opening there for it to do so well I
think it's probably only on
economic terms I don't think that sort
of saber rattling is really going to
save the situation although I do think
that it's an option it has to be kept in
the back pocket so to speak but on the
other hand if it doesn't directly threat
threaten Western in interest to it to a
very damaging extent and the West can
monitor the situation we haven't come to
a situation or a standoff where where
things have got really out of hand but
this may be just that round the corner
we just don't know question tripping if
there's one person in the West who who
can sometimes get through to Vladimir
Putin it is Chancellor Angela Merkel
what if anything can Germany do to try
to bring Russia and the West closer
together again I think what the junk
government led by Angela Merkel is doing
is the only option the West has right
now keep in touch keep in contact talk
as much as you can to make a point to
try to influence your counterpart and at
the same time be firm on sanctions and
be firm on the rule of law which has
been violated by Russia in Ukraine but
there are this option a certain point
might come to an end as well this option
of keeping the communication lines open
what will happen then I don't know Anton
Corian asking what do you think could
bring the climate of fear to an end
I think it I do think that and angle
America always says we need to have a
great deal of patience in waiting this
crisis out and that does seem to be what
even the political opposition in Russia
is accepting this is gonna take a long
time to shake out and its remains a very
unstable situation thank you very much
thanks to all of you for being with us
today and thanks to all of you out there
for tuning in see you soon
you